easy Lifestyle the rolls royces the Jets
he paid so much just to have status
Randall Emmett speaks out against the
upcoming documentary about the
controversies and allegations made
against him last year in a Los Angeles
Times expose I hate randomly
founding that he's somewhere still
playing a victim when what he has
actually done is damage and hurt other
people in a statement to page six on
Tuesday the movie producer defends
himself against the Hulu doc called the
Randall Scandal love loathing and
Vanderpump and slams his ex Vanderpump
Rules star Lala Kent Randall claims the
article was highly biased and a
factually inaccurate hit piece and adds
that the journalists who wrote it seemed
to have a personal Vendetta against him
Randall also alleges the article
featured fictitious and greatly
exaggerated stories from people he calls
disgruntled employees who had been
dismissed soon after the cameras go up
on the season the LA Times expose hits
newsstands hits the internet you've said
that what you've heard is worse than
what's in there so how much worse is
what you've heard it's horrific and
disturbing
and it's why I'm in a custody battle
ocean Kent has to be protected it's like
really bad Lala was one of several women
who shared allegations of inappropriate
and abusive behavior in the piece
published last June but Lala is not a
part of the forthcoming documentary and
neither is Randolph Randall claims he
declined to participate because it
became apparent to him that the film was
going to be as biased if not more so
than the article on which it was based
my family the people with whom I work
and those who matter in my life all know
the truth and my accomplishments I have
nothing to prove do you think that for
the last nine months I have not been
spirally
did you not see it don't you think I
know what has been the biggest aha
moment since
splitting up with Randall I've realized
that I'm so okay by myself that I have
incredible people surrounding me I don't
need a man in the LA Times article Lala
says that an argument in 2021 allegedly
turned violent she claims Randall
violently knocked her to the ground
after she confronted him about allegedly
cheating on her after her Pig surfaced
of Randall with two women in Nashville
the outlet reported the accusation was
confirmed by five people following the
alleged incident Randall denied the
allegation via a spokesperson
Lala and Randall welcomed their first
child together daughter ocean in March
2021 nine months later they called off
their three-year engagement and the
relationship imploded shortly after the
alleged physical fight how do you feel
watching it all back even though it's
strange to relive it it almost is like
wow look how far we've come the Lala
that was on screen was still trying to
process what had happened and now I'm
just I'm swimming when I thought that I
would be sinking so even though I
recognize her it's almost like my heart
goes out to her because we're not there
anymore as for the LA Times They issued
a statement to page six in response to
Randall's allegations if Emmett would
like to dispute any of the facts in our
reporting or the information in the
documentary we welcome him to do so
foreign